if you're a virtual-reality fan this is
the second week in a row you've had
market on their calendar last week was
the oculus rift this week marks the
release of the HTC vive a VR system made
as a partnership between HTC and the
software company valve now since the
system was first announced last year its
promise has always been enabling what
they called room scale VR it was just a
bigger play space it wanted you not just
to sit and stand but to move to walk
around an experienced VR in all of its
splendor of course the price of that is
a set up that's a little bit more
involved and we wanted to put that to
the test
how long would it take me top to get
from box to VR now I can't lie the setup
process for this is kind of involved
each of those lighthouse base stations
which is in the corner of the room those
let you get that 360-degree tracking and
also a larger play space and they need
to be what's recommended as a minimum of
six feet five inches high we were able
to use light stands from the photo
department but they also recommend
drilling those into a wall using their
mounting station so each of those
lighthouse base stations plugs in your
pc obviously plugs in and then there's a
link box that plugs in now there's also
an RCA jack going down in that little
nest of cables down your back and that's
to let you plug in whatever headphones
you have there's no integrated audio on
the vibe like there is with the rift
which is either a pro or con depending
on what side of that audio debate you
fall on even the most pedestrian
just seems like the greatest in the
world I'm making fake popcorn crouched
by a fire oh here it goes
is it going that messed it up
once everything was kind of factored
into it allowing for a couple of snafus
it ended up taking close to an hour to
get set up now that's not so bad
when you first start the set of process
through the vibe application it tells
you you're going to take about 28
minutes give or take so the fact that we
have to do some updates actually pretty
happy with an hour's time however you're
just looking at a lot more cord
management that you might be with the
rift for everything that you get the
wider play area more space that really
cool lighthouse technology you're going
to have to find a little more space to
route your cords and
secrecy I feel like I should do this if
I'm waiting for anything to happen
because you never know ah I died all
right